かかる一変も両方でもあったらいいよねー豚カレーですめっぽうたりうねっ
だろうこれでうわぁああああっにゃんぱプレジャーズロスポンちゃん達ですさあ以前
海辺な教員のドッキリ仕掛けたのを覚えてますかに結構な距離ガースナーヌー
クソしょーもねー
と思いましたえええええええ
って僕も持ってたんですよ結構たくさんやったのに
健康だからかせないんですけどエブリィの量がすごい少なくてあの僕はかなり
裏切られましたこれ糞つまんでになってもて編集してたんだっての踏まえてあるの物量
共友ペアとということで今日はたくさん買ってきました
なんかいろんな要因があったと思うんだよねそもそも部屋が大きいからキュウリ頑張り
前しなかった
立ってるってこれがとびっこしかなかったから煙が自体が少なかったって言う
まあいろんな理由があってまあそいつとしょうまんくなっちゃったんで
今回それを4倍にして何個だこれ40個です
前回10個だったんですけど今回はギョン倍の40個でやっていきたいとおもいます
もつくけどこういう感じでドラムのさと言うとかですもう敵たい時に使うっていうね
俺は完璧な作戦を敢行
れた辺が狭ければいいんですよペア狭ければ煙が溢れねぇ車であります
なーるほどなっ
天才ですはじめスタッフそうだろう貼ってくれると思います
どうやったらそんなことを思いつつああーそれ負ければわかるんですよねそれ以
あげ屋さんこれどうやって使うんですが僕気になって夜も眠れなかったそっかーわけで
やろ
今ですね第一君が海外に行って暇を使ってます
仕掛ける yo ところまでその車に乗って今から帰ってくるんで彫ってきたのは
もちろんここに来ると車に頑張ってを買ってこれを仕掛けに入って
って全部燃やして煙出しまくって車の中も僕も蜘蛛区
具にするとそこでれ中ごめん車に忘れ物したらちょっとってきてやるとかいって言われ
てるきたら車の中後大変
もくもくももっと北区動くは日木曜日ですか a ドッキリをしたいと思いますお空
手帳慌てますそこまで計算して何で天才ですか
つれゲーのリベンジも煙があればかなりヤバイしていい車だと困ると思うんで相当の
迫力になると思いますでは帰ってくるまで待ちましょう
4転載神とポッ
一応はい
[音楽]
tame
くっていた
ん
俺ちょっとコンビニ行ってきます
[音楽]
ten
たて鍵をあっつテックへとリー言ったらのグループの鍵を忘れるやが入ってくるなに
カメラを仕掛けちゃいますね
経費はてブーケ部局にがすごいんだよすぐ車だが入りましょう
ああ
[拍手]
ああああああ
pareja
断じて
やっほ
onnano
植月手続きを築いていきます
私は大丈夫でっ編みができますねっ
が来るんですね
[音楽]
ん
ます
まじかーーーん
とってん
me
ni
dan ああああ
[音楽]
なになになにこれねマってなんかなくっ
まあそういうほどよ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
できたら理由た瞬間煙できてましたよね
健康的ぶりなんでそれはがいない
うおっ製薬すげー
だーっっ
バクはなんてうううううっなんて凄いんだっけ
いやだぞ
慣れないよねぇー
そこからも恐れないけどねっ
ここが漏れて顔れるんだよ